the second season of Batman the telltale
series is right around the corner and
GameSpot's ohm Mike Rizzo had the chance
to sit down and talk with Anthony and
Gruber who plays the voice of John Doe
better known as the Joker and if you
want to see more videos and features of
the new Batman telltale game subscribe
to the GameSpot YouTube channel
playing an earlier version of this
character is actually one of the things
that I'm most exciting about is that i'm
most excited about is because we get to
see this character that is 70 plus years
old and we've all grown up with you know
the iconic ones of you know Mark Hamill
and Heath Ledger and we know those
characters inside and out
but this joker is very it's a very
original take that telltale is doing
indeed with the entire universe is we
see Joker for the first time really as a
sympathetic character and for me
personally as a fan this is the first
time that I see him as someone who
doesn't want to kill the player you know
unless you know through your
interactions with him it'll change his
mind but for the most part if you keep
him happy he'll have your back and I
find that that's such an interesting way
to approach this character who's I mean
he's got this everyone's got their
favorites and we all know the backstory
and stuff and I think telltale are are
taking this in a brand new direction
it's and we're hoping to offer the
players brand new experience so yeah
it's very very cool
well the most compelling thing for me
with this character is that the players
interactions with both John Doe and what
John Doe sees the player doing will
directly affect the experience they have
with this character so if they want the
traditional Batman villain the the
psychotic Clown Prince of Crime they
will go down a darker path and John John
will adjust to that and I think that
will bring out that evil side of the
traditional Joker whereas if you play
you know a good Caped Crusader you know
I'm more of an out of West guy
you'll probably get you know the
trickster loveable you know
family-friendly Joker who'll probably
stay friends with Bruce throughout his
journeys friend's life so I think it
will both deliver a traditional
experience that you know gamers and fans
of Batman will expect from the Joker and
it will also give the other people who
want something new and fresh this
totally you know original interpretation
of this character so it's very
interesting
[Music]
when I was cast for the Joker um I I
found out much later when we wrapped
season 1 that I was found on YouTube
that I actually when I was a teenager
impressions was really the thing that I
was my outlet for my creativity and I'm
doing impressions of you know Jack
Nicholson's Joker and then you look
heavens Joe Cove and then you know the
the classic you know the hello beautiful
you know I put that stuff on YouTube as
a teenager and I learned then that
telltale found that and they said you
know well if he can do those three you
know what what can he create for himself
and so you know when I auditioned I did
those three and then I I did my own sort
of creation which was like a hybrid or
or really you know if this was a
live-action thing how would I do this
and so I just put that on tape as well
and then I was cast and I didn't know
which one they chose so I'm going into
the booth I I initially assumed it would
be the mark hamill because that's you
know the the animated staple and
everyone that's the legend but but they
really wanted me to do something
different
that would make sense in this universe
because if you if you if I tried to
mimic another actor who played in this
original universe that tells I was
creating it wouldn't really make sense
man
so yeah it was very challenging but it
was also you know a lot of fun to have
that freedom the thing is also that we
haven't seen the Joker yet
we've seen John Doe a lot of the
sessions I I record it very you know I
take it on a range so like I'll first go
from jewel like a hundred with you know
a lot of intensity and a lot of you know
volume and aggression and stuff and then
we'll go to a very neutral one and then
telltale will adjust according to the
scene and so butBut washing it myself I
see that they've chosen takes that are
more subdued
or you know like medicated I said I call
if you know and and so later on I'm
really eager to to go full out with this
thing
[Music]
no I still I'm still yet to actually
portray the Joker it's still it's still
John Doe and everything is still still
subdued and then to about half way you
don't ever I haven't really gone full
you know psychosis yes
and the laughs as well as been at times
you know he makes an inappropriate joke
and at the church scene he tells a joke
and it doesn't go over so well so the
laugh he's like you know he realizes no
one else is laughing and I think that's
such a I don't know I find John Doe
quite adorable in his off beat kind of
way it's it's a very sympathetic
character and I love telltale for
betraying him in a different way as
opposed to just a guy who will you know
murder busload of kids for for a joke
you know it's you know it's interesting
yeah I really actually enjoy doing
impressions it's usually the opposite
way where people have to tell me to shut
up you know I actually really enjoy
doing it
I really like I did for Richard II go
here or I go and tell tell I didn't mind
you know why Michael Caine impression I
did you is precious to me as you were to
a mother and father I swore to them that
I would protect you and I have it and
then I did I went for about 20 minutes I
did Bane and and Christian Bale you know
I need a glass can I get a cup okay
looks like it's worth it trust me you
just made a serious mistake
I said let's not stand on ceremony yeah
[Music]
you know I got a repertoire um I also
like doing a bit of math in the kind of
hey if I'm in a bar and I see a
nice-looking girl I just got her and say
hey you know maybe I'd take my shirt off
but you wouldn't have the actual Matthew
McConaughey body underneath that's a bit
of a disappointment